[موسيقى]
منطقه نورماندي بشمال الفرنسي طبيعه خلابه
هواء منعش للنفس وفوق ذلك منتجات محليه
ذات جوده عاليه من بينها عصير التفاح
المخمر
منتج لهذا المشروب الكحولي منذ عشر سنوات
بالنسبه اليه كل شيء يتوقف على هذه
البساتين وما تزخر به من انواع مختلفه
باشجار التفاح
هذا المكان كان لاحد المنتجين الذين كانوا
يصنعون انواعا مختلفه لهذا الشراب
اذا لديكم الوان كثيره من التفاح لدينا
العشرات من انواع التفاح
لا وجود للمواد الكيميائيه في هذه الارض
الممتده على مساحه 20 هكتارا
كان الوضع صعبا جدا في هذا البستان العام
الماضي 15 يوما من الرياح الشماليه
الشرقيه اتلفت اربعه من التفاح قضيت يومين
في نزعها من هنا في الوقت الذي كنت اتوقع
جمع 50 او 60 طنا
من خلال تفاحه المتنوع ساره كيوم يبدع في
انتاجاته ويصنع منتوجات اخرى
في هذا الصباح تنتشر ابخره كحوليه في جميع
انحاء المزرعه بفضل جهاز التقطير العتيق
هذا
لكن لبراعم التذوق الان راي اخر على ما
يبدو
مذاقه حاد جدا
رائحته بصفه خاصه لمعرفه ما اذا كان جيدا
ام تنقصه بعض الاشياء
لا ينقصه اي شيء
وهل وجدت شيئا لا انه جيد لن اقول لكم
العكس على كل حال
لابد ان يعتق نبيذك الفاتوس في هذه
البراميل المصنوعه من خشب البلوط لمده
ثلاث سنوات تماما مثل عصير التفاح الكحولي
صبر طويل من اجل ضمان الجوده
المنتوج الجيد يتطلب التفكير واستمرارا في
تطوير اليات الانتاج اذا قمنا بانتاج شراب
التفاح الكحولي على طريقه انتاج
الكوكاكولا فلن نبيعه بازيد من ثمن
الكوكاكولا
بعيدا عن بساتين التفاح منطقه نورماندي
لديها تقاليدها الخاصه في عالم الصيد هناك
اليوم اكثر من 600 قارب تجوب سواحل بحر
المانش
يستعد بيير وفريقه للابحار في العاده
يذهبون لصيد محاري سنجاك ذهب الابيض
لمنطقه نورماندي لكن اليوم يودون صيد
الاسماك
المعلقه خلف القارب هو حظ كبير بالنسبه
الينا نعلم جيدا مكان المحار في كل مره
نعود الى المكان
صياد ماهر يعرف جيدا خبايا مياه يصول
ويجود فيها منذ عشر سنوات ولا يجد المتعه
الا وهو يقود بشغف قارب الصيف هذا افضل من
العمل في مكتب مقيد طوال اليوم انها
الحريه الكامله قاربه يمثل كل شيء بالنسبه
له قام بانشائه منذ ثلاث سنوات ويشغل معه
اليوم حوالي عشره صيادين حلم الطفوله التي
تحقق بعد مشوار
مرت علي سنتان لم اذق فيهما طعم الراحه
اطلاقا
انت مكافح بارع
لانها ببساطه الحرفه التي نجني من خلالها
المال دون مواصله الدراسه بين الدراسه
والعمل اخترت سريعا هذا المشوار لكن
المنافسه في مياه المونش شديده في بعض
الاحيان
كلما نزل الانجليز للصيد وجب علينا
الاسراعه في الصيد لانهم يمتلكون وسائل
اكبر من وسائلنا انها الحرب
في الوقت الذي يعود فيه الصيادون الى
الميناء يوجد بعيدا من هنا من يخرج ابقار
النورماندي الخاص به للراي كم انت جميله
تقضي هذه الابقار تسعه اشهر من السنه في
هذه المراعي ارض رطبه كانت تشتمل ذات يوم
على احد اكبر بحيرات في اوروبا لذلك تعد
تربتها اليوم خصبه بامتياز في مروج واحده
بامكاننا ايجاد قرابه 100 نوع من النباتات
بين البقوليات واعشاب
كاملا بالنسبه للابقار
تنتج كل يوم الف ومئتين لتر من حليب عضوي
100%
انه جيد جزء من هذا الحليب يستخدم في صنع
زبده النورماندي الشهيره
انه لذيذ جدا وسهل المعالجه ودهني وذو لون
ناصح زبده صفراء فاقع لونها ستصنع شهره
قريه اذن النورمانديه الشهيره اعتبارا من
القرن السابع عشر يستخدمها هذا المعمل عام
1934 لصناعه الكراميل
منذ ذلك الحين صار كراميلو ايزيني عالميا
المنتجات محليه الوصفه بسيطه ولم تتغير
زبده وسكر وحليب وكريمه وتحضر في هذه
الاواني وسط مئه وخمسه وعشرين درجه مئويه
بمجرد ان يبرد يعجن الكراميل باليد ثم
يقطع ويستخدم في انواع شتى تصل الى 25
نوعا كالزبده العاديه والمالحه والحلوى
الصغيره
نحن الان بصدد تحضير كريم الكراميل كريمه
جيده خاصه بقريتنا ايزيني لكن هذا
الكراميل يعلق بالاسنان
كراميل قريه ايزيني ساره من اكثر الاشياء
التي تشتهر بها المنطقه مثل الصيد والعديد
من المنتجات الاخرى التي تعد ثمره جهود
اشخاص وخبرات نورمانديه خالصه